for the people who don't know
what is your uh is the
give us the big sean backstory let's
talk about it what's up yeah
you still call him that call him little
sean in my eyes
uh yo big shot low-key yoked right now
though
yeah that's what i'm saying he is joke
shot of him that was just a joke bruh so
um i was on the podcast so it was my my
ex
um she used to work at this restaurant
and she was a hostess yeah he came in
and i remember i used to pick her up
from work and i was picking up that one
day
and uh i guess he i don't know i can't i
don't say the year but i can't remember
the year
but um uh he slid her
his number hmm how was i and he was a
handsome tip you know i was like you
[ __ ] with money you know
you know how beautiful that girl is you
know she's gonna you know he hopped in
that goddamn bins
and then she came to me and you know i
don't wanna put my minutes out there but
i was driving a central that's not at
least you were driving the brian pumper
mobile
well goddamn i didn't have my clothes in
the car [ __ ] okay okay he said i
had a house at least
yeah [ __ ] it was clean it was clean no
notes i had no notes on it
well no what kind of notes that man
paying on he was his release i own my
[ __ ]
uh nah but uh she got in the car and
uh you know of course you know she go
she's gonna do what she do
so so she texts did she text big sean so
i
i was so she was like man i'm going out
with my friends one night right and i
was like all right cool do your thing
i ain't tripping it is like one o'clock
i was like i haven't heard from my baby
let me give her a little dial so i
called her
he said boy no hey no it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't it was going straight
to voicemail oh that's yeah that's
like texting her and it wasn't i was
like is her phone off right
right then it finally came back on i'm
calling her calling her and then i'm in
the car at this point
and i'm going by her crib and you know
she lived it was like she lived on
imperial way at the time
and it was like uh uh you can see her
parking spot yeah like from the street
so i'm driving by
it's still i'm like she ain't home yet
and i'm i'm circling like i'm patrolling
a little bit
you know i'm this young guy i've been
there i've been there she i couldn't she
butt down me back
i heard it all ass ass ass ass i'm like
you [ __ ] you know what i mean
but
you heard big sean on the phone i heard
i heard i heard her
all i heard was you want to have another
drink and then i was like she was like
yeah sure i was
my heart sunk into my goddamn stomach it
went to my goddamn stomach i was like
i was in the car i just you know how sad
you is when you just get out the car
turn the hyzer lights on and just start
walking with no direction yeah i know
where i was going
i was just i just needed to walk and
then i i finally got back to my car
because i mean that was a short walk
because i was in the hood and um
right he's like you know what bad
decision
let me go back to that section i'm
trying to go back to that guy where it's
safe uh
i could cry in the car yeah yeah you
want to kill me sad air
you know yeah and yeah that was that was
a whole thing
but uh and i just kind of like i just
leaned into um
you leaned into it well at least big
sean helped expose the relationship that
probably wasn't gonna last either either
way right yeah because
yeah the reason why they call uh you
know
your ex you know yeah yeah she was bad
though
she having only fans now nah i hope so
if she had an only fans would you
subscribe to your ex's only fans
ah because i mean oh man i already know
what that looked like
you know i mean i'm cool on that because
then you know i mean you have feelings
and i'm like no i'm good on that
you know again but she bad though nobody
now she ever say hi to me again all is
forgiven i swear now just mess with you